eine neue ära der wissenschaft beginnt
noch dieses jahr können videos von
atommüll in bewegung gemacht werden die
alles übertreffen was es bisher gab die
rede ist von der lineg kohärent light
source to des us-energieministeriums
10.000 mal schneller als sein vorgänger
wird er völlig neue
forschungsmöglichkeiten schaffen die
bausteine des universums
könnten wir in nie da gewesene auflösung
in bewegung beobachten das wird die
menschheit jetzt zum ersten mal erfahren
eine neue ära der wissenschaft es schon
bald sehr bald beginnt sikhs umsonst ein
feature gibt es dreimal pro woche
spannende science wie das abonniert den
kanal und aktiviert die glocke nur so
verpasst ihr nichts los geht's
herzlich willkommen was das james webb
weltraumteleskop auf der makroebene ist
das ist dieser röntgenlaser auf der
mikroebene dieser röntgen esa ist
wirklich ein riesenfortschritt er gehört
zum snack dem stanford linear
accelerator center umbenannt in national
accelerator laboratory stanford
kalifornien usa wobei die abkürzung
geblieben ist der laser ist so dermaßen
schnell und präzise dass der atome in
bewegung beobachten kann die rede ist
von seinem vorgänger linie current light
source lcls
dem vorgänger der bereits 2009 in
betrieb genommen wurde seitdem hat
dieser röntgenlaser schon einiges ab
liefert bisher nie dagewesene bilder der
atomaren welt kommt mit seiner hilfe
erzeugt werden wir werden puls erzeugt
die nur einige millionstel sekunden lang
sind dadurch wird es dem leser
ermöglicht besonders scharfe bilder von
bewegten atom und chemischen reaktionen
zu erzeugen so können nicht nur die
spannenden eigenschaften von materialien
untersucht werden die lcls ist sogar in
der lage in lebende organismen
hineinzuschauen um stoffwechselprozesse
zu beobachten doch jetzt wird ein
weiterer laser in stanford fertig
gestellt der das alles noch einmal
übertrumpft und dieser neue leser könnte
die forschung von den bausteinen des
universums grundlegend verändern die
linie in light source lcls to wird somit
der zweite röntgenlaser von weltrang am
slac national accelerator laboratory das
ziel der entwicklerinnen und entwickler
ist nicht ohne denn die lcls two soll
nicht weniger als der hälfte röntgen
leser der welt werden bis zu 10.000 mal
schneller als sein vorgänger könnte
somit eine neue ära der wissenschaft
eingeleitet werden wie genau soll das
funktionieren und was können wir von dem
neuen leser wirklich erwarten die
antworten auf all diese spannenden
fragen um noch viel mehr jetzt hier bei
bigsim future forschungsteams weltweit
setzen schon lange auf die arbeit von
lesern denn damit können sie runter auf
die atomare ebene messen und analysieren
wie sich teilchen bewegen die bislang
als nicht messbarkeit einblick in die
quantenphysik hinein noch vor jahren
schien das undenkbar zudem können super
schnelle prozesse und extreme zustände
erforscht werden spannend also für viele
verschiedene wissenschaftszweige unter
anderem die chemie physik biologie und
astronomie biologinnen und biologen sind
dadurch in der lage
molekülstrukturen aufzuklären zu werden
nicht mehr länger moleküle in ihrer
kristallinen form benötigt um ihre atom
zusammensetzung zu entschlüsseln bereits
sehr kleine qualitativ minderwertige
kristall erreichen dafür mittlerweile
aus um die zusammensetzung mit der hilfe
von unseren lesern zu entschlüsseln
langfristig könnten solche experimente
dann natürlich auch über die
grundlagenforschung hinaus geht denn
dadurch durch die aufklärung von protein
molekülstrukturen beispielsweise lassen
sich neue arzneimittel entwickeln die
fachwelt denkt zum beispiel ganz konkret
an der entwicklung neuer schmerzmittel
oder mittel um antibiotikaresistenzen
endlich zu überwinden auch im bereich
der chemie leisten röntgenlaser
sensationelle erfolge mit ihrer hilfe
lassen sich bislang nicht messbare
chemische reaktion nennt es zum beispiel
chemieunterricht manche chemische
reaktionen sind so komplex dass die
moleküle so schnell von einer
zwischenstufe in die nächste übergehen
dass dies von konventionellen detektoren
bislang nicht messbar war also kein
wunder warum viele in der schule so
schlecht in chemie sind das ist wirklich
nur schwer zu verstehen weil wir darüber
noch so wenig wissen oder physik die
intensiven röntgenstrahlen machen das
tatsächlich möglich aktuelle zu
ionisieren ihnen also einen teil der
elektronen wegzuschießen so lässt sich
unter anderem erforschen die sich
materie in der sonnenatmosphäre verhält
aber auch die eigenschaften von plasma
lassen sich so ermitteln dabei ist es
mir eigentlich nur so kurz stabil dass
seine analyse bis dann fast unmöglich
erschien
vielversprechende experimente mit einem
röntgenlaser laufen auch in deutscher
die rede ist vom hamburger profi nix
fällt der eine zeit lang tatsächlich als
der stärkste und dem leser der welt galt
die abkürzung steht für x-raid free
electron laser also übersetzt so viel
wie freier röntgenlicht elektronen
lasern mit hilfe von ultra schnellen
runden in blitzen wird hier das sichtbar
gemacht was bislang im verborgenen blieb
ein teilchenbeschleuniger sorgt dafür
dass elektronen wolken aus einem stück
metall herausgelöst und beschleunigt
werden auf einer strecke von zwei
kilometern erreichen sie dann fast
lichtgeschwindigkeit der elektronen
wolken sind also unvorstellbar schnell
und energiereich spezielle magnete
bringen sie dann in einen zick-zack-kurs
so dass die elektronen licht abstrahlen
das licht ist schneller als der
elektronen und überholt sie deswegen
dadurch werden einige elektronen
abgebremst und langsamer andere werden
schneller andere ändern ihre
bewegungsrichtung es bilden sich gruppen
beziehungsweise scheiben die alle im
gleichen takt strahlen die so
entstehende röntgenstrahlung wird durch
die wechselwirkung mit den elektronen
immer stärker röntgenblitze entstehen
unglaubliche 27.000 intensive
röntgenblitze pro sekunde entstehen so
im european xfel ja sie sind unfassbar
kurz dauern weniger als 100
millisekunden und haben eine wellenlänge
von bis zu einem zehntel nanometer so
viel wie etwa der abstand zwischen zwei
atome moleküle und das ist genau der
punkt mit diesen blitzen können
unglaublich kleine struktur moleküle zum
beispiel beobachtet wird nur um das
unglaubliche daran noch einmal zu
verdeutlichen berechnet man die blitze
auf einem quadratzentimeter fläche sind
sie zehn trilliarden mal intensiver als
das sonnenlicht möglich kaum vorstellbar
diese röntgenblitze werden dann auf
verschiedene instrumente geleitet an
denen experimente durchgeführt werden
die lineg für herren gletschers zu kurz
lcls to in kalifornien soll das toppen
sie wird bis zu einer million pulse pro
sekunde erzeugen und somit ein strahl
der noch mal 10.000 mal schneller ist
als der seines vorgängers
dieser war bereits in der lage ein
strahlen mit 120 lichtimpulsen pro
sekunde zu produzieren doch die
funktionsweise des upgrades ist eine
andere der beschleuniger der lcls
schiebt elektronen durch eine kupfer
röhre die bei raumtemperatur arbeitet
nur in kurzen stößen aktiviert werden
soll anders dagegen die lcls tue denn
sie ist für den dauerbetrieb ausgelegt
im klartext bedeutet das also dass
extreme wärme mengen erzeugt werden
statt einen kupfer hohlraum der viel
wärme absolvieren würde musste also eine
andere lösung her das ergebnis ist ein
neuer supraleitender beschleuniger der
aus zahlreichen sogenannten modulen
besteht diese sind für den betrieb bei
zwei grad über dem absoluten nullpunkt
ausgelegt eine gigantische creo gen
anlage ist dafür nötig die extrem tiefe
temperaturen erzeugen kann und die
anlage somit auf betriebstemperatur hält
die beteiligten forscher hoffen so
bislang unmögliche experimente möglich
zu machen dazu sagt einer der forscher
vor ort denn screen ich denke man kann
mit fug und recht behaupten dass die
lcls zu eine neue ära der wissenschaft
einleiten wird demnach ist der laser in
der lage impulse bis unter zu einer
femtosekunde zu erzeugen eine
femtosekunde ist für eine sekunde so
viel wie eine sekunde für das alter des
universums
es handelt sich quasi um ein mikroskop
dass eine atomare auflösung ermöglicht
noch nie haben wir also tiefer in atome
und moleküle geschaut und das
funktioniert folgendermaßen ein
teilchenbeschleuniger beschleunigt
teilchen und lenkt sie in einen strahl
der dann durch eine reihe von wechseln
magneten geleitet wird so entstehen dann
röntgenstrahlen mit ihrer hilfe können
letztlich dann richtige filme genauer
gesagt molekular film erzeugt werden
schnappschüsse von molekülen und atomen
die sich in bewegung befinden die
innerhalb weniger bild zehn sekunden
aufgenommen werden und dann wie ein film
an einander gereiht werden und das ist
spannend für alle möglichen bereiche in
der wissenschaft bereits mit dem
vorgänger der ersten lcls konnten so
spektakuläre und aufschlussreiche
molekular film erzeugt werden diese
zeigen die chemische reaktion in
echtzeit unter anderem das verhalten von
atomen im sternen inneren auch live
schnappschüsse von der photosynthese
gelangen so doch diese molekulare filme
sollen mit der hilfe der lcls tut noch
einmal getoppt werden dazu sagt andy
borg der das labor leitet wenn man sich
ein stroboskop sich vorstellt dass 120
mal ausgelöst wird sieht man ein bild
wenn es eine million mal in einer
sekunde losgeht erhält man ein ganz
anderes bild man kann also einen viel
besseren film erstellen diese deutlich
höhere pulsrate der lcls to wird also zu
spektakulären erkenntnissen führen da
sind sich alle wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler sicher man kann sich das
wie die bildfrequenz bei einem
videospiel vorstellen statt nur zugucken
fließt die bewegung jetzt flüssig und
man kann details in der bewegung viel
besser erkennen vor allem beben im
zeitablauf quasi mit einer million
bildern pro sekunde
forschende haben unter anderem das ziel
spannende fragen zu beantworten die bis
heute trotz intensiver forschung
unbeantwortet geblieben sind mit dabei
unter anderem die folgenden großen
fragen wie genau können wir uns die
energieübertragung in molekularen system
vorstellen wie läuft die ladung
übertragung ab auf den ersten blick
klingt das vielleicht ziemlich
theoretisch doch die
anwendungsmöglichkeiten sind groß ein
tieferes verständnis dieser prozesse
könnte uns dazu in die lage versetzen
künstliche photosynthese zu betreiben
und bessere solarzellen zu bauen noch
anfangen diesen jahres 2022 soll der
erste elektronenstrahl in der lcls to
erzeugt werden im sommer dann der erste
röntgenstrahl die beteiligten
forschenden erwarten dieses große licht
ereignis mit großer freude und noch an
anderer stelle können wir den quanten ja
quasi auf die finger gucken die wunder
der quanten können wir bald mit bloßem
auge sehen quantenphysik wird zur
realität das ist auch eine absolut
bahnbrechende entwicklung also anklicken
anschauen und abonnieren das geht ganz
einfach und kostet nichts mit dem abo
button unter jedem video bis dann